baby Smith de 58 años británico nacido
en Escocia y quien trabajaba como
guardia de seguridad en la embajada
británica en Berlín Se declaró culpable
de 8 delitos bajo la ley de secretos
oficiales la justicia británica cree que
empezó a entregar información sensible
confidencial al gobierno ruso desde el
2018 por sumas de dinero pero aclaró el
juez que ninguna de estas era para
cambiarle la vida explicó además el juez
que ese origen de entregar información
sensible británica al gobierno ruso
radicaba en ese sentimiento anti
británico y anti occidental pero muy
prorruso dijo el juez que recolectó una
cantidad significativa de material para
dañar los intereses británicos y
proporcionó esa información a un poder
hostil entre la información confidencial
entregada está la correspondencia confi
del entonces Primer Ministro Boris
Johnson con la embajada de Berlín un
elemento clave para el gobierno
británico también entregó información
secreta como fotos y detalles muy
personales de todos los trabajadores de
la embajada y un video de las
instalaciones de la sede diplomática
británica en la capital alemana